this is not accurate these cameras were
never designed for sunscreen testing one
swipe is probably giving you maybe spf3
at most our eyes don't see UV and
cameras can only detect long wavelength
UVA because most UV wavelengths don't go
through glass so there's a lot of
processing that has to happen to convert
the UV signal to black and white so that
we can see it it's like auto-tune it
isn't an accurate version of reality UV
cameras are just designed for
qualitative information did you put the
sunscreen on that spot yes or no they
aren't good for telling you how much you
need weight is a much better way of
measuring because all SPF labels are
based on testing after applying two
milligrams per square centimeter I did a
bunch of experiments to work out how
many swipes of the sunscreen stick you
need to apply on average you need over
30 swipes to get the labeled SPF we can
also check how heavy the sunscreen is
the weight in grams is roughly how many
full face applications you have in your
stick